Many of these drugs are produced in the
state of Guerrero and that has caused
a fight for the territories
in a report on the exact
occasion where the heroin comes from this bulb
is where it comes from this is the
poppy plant where its flower is its  bulbo and
here you could see this one that has already been
worked on, two scratches were made here
to remove the rubber
papi
ryan speaker sets it will be much more money
and now more economy more more more
resources more and more behind clover we know
it's illegal but somehow  it is the
only thing that many people have to stay
arturo to the movies james bond and
expand business billions to english
oliver to see and be loved stein
and what is the connection between violence
the need to create other defenses
the poppy more than anything i think it is
the issue of criminal gangs
because there are places
where people have not organized
so one gang enters another and
another enters and they charge people to
go up to get there  for selling whatever he charges them
[Music]